all right so this is a golden movie room
when you see a movie that has a poster
that looks like that you know it's going
to be all class project X my how 25
years changes everything 25 years ago
project X was a Matthew Broderick movie
about chimps who flying get blasted with
radiation and die and scare me as a kid
now it's about parties less scary ish
unless you're a parent so Project X is
yet another found footage movie but it's
not really a found footage movie because
the footage was never lost it was never
lost and it can't be found it's a movie
that's filmed to look like it was filmed
with home camcorders and it follows
these three high school students who are
like we need to be cool we need to make
a name for ourselves we need a game
changer let's throw a huge party hey
well your parents are away nerdy one of
the group okay let's do that
and after that chaos anarchy and a sweet
party ensues now here's the way I see
Project X I think if you're able to lay
down the artists fan inside of you I
think you'll be able to enjoy Project X
after the slow part passes I mean at the
beginning you're like all right it's a
little slow at first that kid who's
talking to the camera the whole time
he's really annoying he's like Shia
LaBeouf's Dumber clones I also call
on him like how old is that kid
he looks 30 I checked IMDB to check his
age his age is not listed so he's most
definitely at least thirty but after
that passes the party starts you're like
yeah this is pretty fun and then insane
stuff starts happening you're like this
is really fun and then destruction and
mayhem in your life this is out of this
world
awesome I'm not gonna lie to
you I had fun with Project X I didn't
think I was going to I was like all
right mindless highschool party movie
how can I relate to that
I myself was nerdy in high school I
never went to a party like this in high
school and after high school still
haven't gone to a party like this but
I've seen some cool events like
this are fun when you're there it's just
undeniable so I enjoyed it and I'm
vicariously now living through high
school students on the big screen who
aren't really high school students at
one of them's 35 I guess I'm that
pathetic but I don't care what's the
point of this movie not sure no idea
don't care this movie is not made for
you to walk out of the theater and be
like yes what was the point of that
well the deeper meaning of life in
Project X is it as deep is blasting
radiation into chimps in the old project
X I do know it's not a movie that you
need to go and see if you never see
Project X in your life you're gonna be
fine however if you do go and see
Project X you're gonna have a good time
with it if drinking and partying high
school movies appeal to you that is
don't be like well I liked Chronicle
apparently I like those found footage
type movies it does not really don't do
that drinking drugs idiots hot chicks
and Archy chaos destruction at your
friend's parents house which makes it a
lot better if that appeals to you you
might like Project X I would say it was
a good time for me no alcohol required
but I'm going to say for you it's going
to be a good time when you're drunk
I say when not if because who are we
kidding you're gonna see this movie
while you're shit-faced hammered let's
all be realists here when they strapped
balloons to the dog and things floating
in the air how do you not laugh at that
so your favorite party movie whatever it
may be
comment below let me know there's no
time limit on this either you want to
say Porky's say Porky's in any case if
you like what you seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more